お世話して、えっと、何とか
シューマーキス、私はコロンビアでシューマーキス
で、シューマーキスは本当に必ず
乗らなくてもいいんです
父親もね、あの、ずっと、父親もこうやって
あれ、そうなんだ
私は、父親が好きなのは、えっと、
走れる、コロで、なんでかと言うと
ちょうばさ、これじゃないでしょ
えっと、日本語でいいんですよ
一緒にちょっと乗りましたよね、チェバでね
ひもで、つけて、えっと、ま、曲がる、曲がる
シュー、わからない日本語でと言いますか
チェバ作か
チェバ作、そう、チェバ作
チェバ作が、えっと、簡単にやるじゃない?
でも、これがオーマーの決まりです
とても、
ひもつけてないと、どこか行っちゃうんですよ
ちょうばさく、こうやってれば、自分は操作しなくても、同じ円運動で、こう、ぐるぐるぐる回ってくれるんで、そこで自分のバランスを練習するんですね
それが、非常に楽しい、非常に楽しい
それが、その後は、気分がいいときに、ジャンプして、なんとか嬉しい
ジャンプは、面白いです
ジャンプ
今は、最高で2mぐらいまで飛びますから、いい馬は
ジャンプは、その、ね、障害がないと、最高だと、高さになって、パーっと横に
オリンピックだと、160とか、このぐらいの障害までは、取れないと
それは大事です
いや、これで、筋肉とかエネルギーとか、すごい
うん
なんか、どうやって
あと、あの、最後まで、あの、元気で、お会いしてたの、あの、高山先生って、あの、パシャーかたのか、知ってられてました
たぶん、よく知ってますけど、そこで教えていただいて、されるくらい
もう少し。もう一回。車。
馬は疲れた時に教えまでしてるじゃない。
もういいから。
面白いですよね。